فيما يلي بعض من أكثر
الصور غير المسبوقة والمفيدة للشمس التي تم
التقاطها على الإطلاق ، والتي أصبحت ممكنة بفضل هاتين
الآليتين المسبار الشمسي باركر التابع لناسا ، وأرسلت
وكالة الفضاء الأوروبية
مركبة الإقلاع الشمسية المدارية من قبل
ناسا في أغسطس من عام 2018 مع
تتبع المركبة الشمسية المدارية  في فبراير 2020 ،
تخطط باركر للقيام بـ 24 تمريرة
حول الشمس قبل انتهاء مهمتها في عام 2025 ،
وستقوم المركبة الشمسية المدارية
بالاقتراب من الشمس كل 6 أشهر
حتى 20 30 على الأقل.
وقد تم إرسالها للتحقيق في
الأسئلة الرئيسية حول النجم.  في
مركز نظامنا الشمسي ، ما يدفع
الدورة المغناطيسية التي تبلغ 11 عامًا ، ما الذي يسخن
الهالة ، حيث تأتي الرياح الشمسية من
الإجابات على هذه الأسئلة ، يمكن أن يمنحنا
فهمًا أفضل لكيفية تأثير الشمس
على طقس الفضاء
ولحماية الأقمار الصناعية التي نعتمد عليها بشكل أفضل  في
الأنشطة اليومية هنا على الأرض ،
فلماذا يوجد مسباران منفصلان
أطلقتهما وكالتان فضاء مختلفتان
لمراقبة نفس الشمس
فذلك لأنهما  تتمتع
بقدرات تكميلية ووجهات نظر للشمس
تساعد على توسيع المعلومات التي
تجمعها ، على سبيل المثال لا تستطيع الكاميرات
البقاء على قيد الحياة عند النظر مباشرة إلى الشمس من
أقرب مكان مثل باركر ، لذا فإن المركبة الشمسية
ستلتقط صورًا
للشمس وتجمع معلومات السياق من
ما  يراقب باركر
خطط المركبة المدارية الشمسية للاقتراب
من الشمس بمقدار 26 مليون ميل أي
أقل من ثلث متوسط المسافة على الأرض من
لشمس با
كر سيقترب سبع مرات من حا
ل الرقم القياسي لممر شمسي يط
ر إلى هالة الشمس في غضون 3.8 مل
ون  أميال من سطحه ، إذا كانت الشمس
يمكن أن تجعلك شديد الحرارة هنا على الأرض ،
تخيل أن تكون قريبًا منه ،
وقد تم تصميم باركر خصيصًا
لتحمل درجات حرارة تقترب من 2500
درجة فهرنهايت لحماية نفسها ،
وقد تم تجهيز باركر بغطاء شمسي مداري
مركب من الكربون بسمك 4.5 بوصة
السفر بعيدًا
يجب أن يتحمل درجات حرارة تزيد عن
930 درجة فهرنهايت ولكنه مناسب
مع الكاميرات التي تحتاج إلى النظر إلى
الشمس ، لذا فإن الدرع الحراري للمركبة الشمسية
يحتوي في الواقع على ثقوب محفورة فيها
للسماح للضوء بالدخول إلى
مدار باركر ، يأخذها عبر
هالة الشمس لأخذ عينات من المكان الذي
تنفصل فيه بلازما الإكليل ليصبح متوقفًا للرياح الشمسية
يحمل معه أربعة أدوات
لدراسة المجالات المغناطيسية للبلازما
والجسيمات النشطة
ولتصوير الرياح الشمسية وكيف تسرع
المدار الشمسي لا يطير في مدار ثابت
ولكنه يتناغم مع الزهرة
باستخدام سحب الجاذبية للكوكب
كل بضعة تمريرات لمحاولة
تحويل مداره تدريجيًا إلى  حوالي 33 درجة
فوق خط الاستواء الشمسي تقدم
مناظر لم يسبق لها مثيل
للمناطق القطبية للشمس
ولماذا تفعل هذه المجسات ذلك الآن
لأن الشمس تتجه نحو
ما يعرف باسم الحد الأقصى للشمس
وهو ذروة النشاط الشمسي كل 11
عامًا
في اليوم التالي  من المتوقع حدوث الذروة في
يوليو 2025 ، لذا فهذه هي أفضل
فرصة لهم لمعرفة الكثير عن
الشمس ومدى ارتباطها بنا.  كانت موجودة على
الأرض حتى عام 2036